Speaker 1: A visibly scared Donald Trump flipped
out during a gala the other day over a special
counsel being selected by Merrick Garland
to investigate his crimes. You have to see
Trump at this thing. He was in rare form, and I
don't mean because he was wearing a tuxedo and
looking more orange than ever, although
that was notable and interesting to see
Trump saying, Isn't this all kind of
like double jeopardy impeachment hoax?
Speaker 3: And by.
Speaker 1: The way, I apologize for the terrible
audio. That's an issue in the room. Apparently,
the audio techs must have been Antifa or sex.
Speaker 3: And they tried it in
the Senate. They went through the
whole process and we won. We went through the
whole process. So wouldn't this sort of be a
and then you take a look at the other. We went
through two of them and it is sort of like double
jeopardy. In the old days, they used to call
it double jeopardy. But essentially we've done
so well and we did well in a very hostile court.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's not double jeopardy. Double
jeopardy is the prosecution of a person more
than once for the same offense. Trump thinks
double jeopardy is. They keep finding out of
new crimes you might have committed and those
crimes are investigated. He's clearly scared.
He's clearly making no sense. And there was a
hilarious statement, actually, that Trump gave
to Fox Digital where he said, quote, I have been
proven innocent for six years on everything
from fake impeachment to Mueller who found no
collusion. And now I have to do it more. I am not
going to partake in it. I announce and then they
appoint a special prosecutor. The appointment of
the special prosecutor, right after he announces,
is the proper thing to do. Not doing it would
be a problem. And of course Trump is wrong that
he has been proven innocent. He doesn't seem
to understand how anything works. He also was
impeached for things that they weren't fake. They
mostly happened in public and they're recorded.
Mueller did not find no collusion. Mueller
decided not to prosecute, and Trump saying
he won't partake, won't really do anything.
It doesn't make it go away. Back to the gala.
Trump commenting on the special counsel.
He said, I thought that was case closed.
Speaker 3: This horrendous abuse of power is
the latest in a long series of which, yes,
we started a long time ago. I thought the
investigation with the document hoax was dying or
dead or over. And the investigation into January
six and my very peaceful and patriotic speech,
remember, peaceful and patriotically was
dead, especially after the record setting
40 point loss of Liz Cheney. And the great.
Speaker 1: Seems to think that because
Cheney lost the investigation, the
criminal investigation is over. I mean,
just the total lack of understanding of anything.
Speaker 3: State of Wyoming, I said, was that I
thought that put the final nail in the coffin
only to find out that the corrupt and highly
political Justice Department just appointed
a super radical left special counsel that are
referred to as a special prosecutor to start
the process all over again. We thought it was.
Speaker 1: This guy is scared. You can genuinely
tell there is absolutely fear there. And then he
went into his bizarre hyperbole like saying
there is no one more innocent than Trump.
Speaker 3: I've proven to be one of the most
honest and innocent people ever in our country,
proven to be one of the most honest and
innocent people ever in our country.
Speaker 1: Trump, speaking at the same
gala, actually brought up Carrie Lake
and said, What happened with her is incredible
and that that isn't even over. Check this out.
Speaker 3: Carrie Lake, who just
went through an incredible election.
There were a lot of broken voting
machines. You heard that lateral and
happy to be in largely Republican
areas and there wouldn't have been.
There is a disgrace. But I want to
just tell you, you did some job,
Gary. And I know it's not over yet.
Speaker 1: It is over. It is over. And there
were a few tabulators that for a period of time
were not working in some parts of Maricopa County.
Everything was fixed that the GOP, which had filed
a lawsuit, retracted the lawsuit. Kerry Lake lost.
It is over. Donald Trump also started calling for
the feds to invade the homes of the Clintons and
the Bushes, which was a very strange moment.
Speaker 3: They have to invade. This is Mar a
Lago. They have to invade. Hillary and
Bill Clinton's beautiful home in West
Chester. They have to invade the bushes
home. They have to invade a lot of homes.
But they didn't do that. And they took
documents. They took a lot of things. And that's
what we have the Presidential Records Act for.
Speaker 1: Them calling for. You know, it's funny.
On the one hand, he says law enforcement and the
FBI have been politicized and weaponized and now
he's saying they should do it to the Bushes
and Clintons, even though they aren't actually
invest under investigation for any crimes.
And then lastly, this is just kind of funny,
even C-SPAN pulling away from coverage of this.
Speaker 3: Chicago recently had 82 people shot
82 over the weekend, but they said it was a
long weekend. Oh, okay. That's flattering.
It was a long weekend in Afghanistan. When
I was in charge, we didn't have one killing.
Think of it. In 18 months now, one of
our soldiers were killed. And then you
look at Chicago and you look at other.
Speaker 2: And former President Trump
has moved on to other topics. We'll take this
opportunity to move on with our program schedule.
Speaker 1: That's the best. Other topics Trump's
entire speeches are moving on are moving on to
other topics. That's all he does. Move on to other
topics. So absolutely surreal. He looks terrified.
He looks genuinely terrified. We will have all
of these clips on our Instagram. And remember,
we are preparing for 2024 as well, pushing for 2
million YouTube subscribers. Last month, more than
3 million different YouTube viewers watched clips
but didn't subscribe. Help us get to 2 million
simply by hitting the subscribe button right now.
If you are not yet subscribed to the channel,
we could do it overnight just with our existing
viewers. If they hit that subscribe button,
help us out. We're going to take a quick
break and be back with so much more. We're
going to talk about the runoff. We're going
to talk about VP. So many different things